it looks like the strikes might be
coming to an end but what's happened
where are we at and what does it mean
for things like Stargate welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so last night the wga and the big
studios came to a tentative agreement
basically they've agreed most of the
points of what both sides have been
arguing about and they're now just
writing up sort of the legalese the
actual contract that they can then vote
upon and actually get back to work it
does actually look like they could even
be back to work by the end of the week
because at the moment they are sort of
denied the ability to write and work
because of the strike that though will
be removed and they will be allowed to
get back to work while waiting for the
agreement to be ratified so what were we
actually see straight away well you will
see like the late night shows will come
back almost immediately in America and a
lot of those live shows where there are
writers behind the scenes who'll be able
to get back straight away but it also
means that chances are the big studios
will be able to start at least thinking
about restarting a lot of the projects
that they've had to put on pause now the
actors are still on strike but they are
next so sag after the scream Actors
Guild will begin negotiations almost
immediately the thing is though a lot of
the issues that the actors have really
do mirror the issues that the writers
had like Ai and Staffing levels and
basically minimum pay and things like
this it was always really expected that
whatever deal the writer struck the
actors would probably accept something
at least similar the writers and the
actors have really been in solidarity
through this entire process so now the
writers are happy well I'm actually told
that this deal is okay for both sides
acceptable but neither side is actually
ecstatic about it so nobody's won but
nobody's lost some told that the writers
are reasonably happy with this and this
will then be used as a model to take to
the app actors and the expectation is
that that deal will be signed reasonably
quickly as well but actually the studios
were always focused on the writers first
they went on strike first and actually
they need to get back to work first
there's an awful lot of projects on the
go that actually aren't at the filming
stage anyway so the fact that the actors
are still on strike isn't a major
problem the Studios really need the
writers to get to work first and then if
it's another week or two till the actors
come back to work that's okay but what
does this mean for things like RoboCop
Stargate a million other projects that
we're waiting for well as you know we
really focus on Stargate on this channel
that's the thing that we desperately
want and this is the thing that we keep
our eye on most closely I've been able
to get some really amazing information
and some good sources and most recently
actually start talking to a quite high
up Source actually at MGM
they've been able to confirm to me that
yes they were very close to actually
announcing the Stargate project and it
is going to be a movie they actually
already do have a script in place but
they didn't want to announce anything
while the strikes are going on so there
is no reason not to expect that Stargate
won't be announced quite quickly
because that's a double triple negative
I'm not sure so what we can expect is a
Stargate announcement and I think but
this is just my opinion it'll be before
Christmas that we will get something
announced and actually I suspect the
project is much further along than we
know and actually we could get even
principal photography relatively quickly
so that's where we're at with the
strikes they are pretty much coming to
an end what they really should be over
by the end of the week for the writers
at least and then we're expecting to
hear something for the actors pretty
quickly not long after we cannot say any
more than we are glad this is now coming
to an end it was going to eventually of
course and it's took a lot longer than
we were hoping but some experts were
saying that this might not get resolved
until April next year so we're just glad
that it was much sooner the studios want
these guys back to work we want these
guys back to work with a deal that that
is at least okay for all sides and it
looks like we're getting it but guys
give the comments to what you think what
does this mean for projects like
Stargate because I know at the end of
the day that's what we're really waiting
for do you agree with me that actually
within the next two months we could get
an announcement I think it could even be
quicker than that but I'm trying to be
sensible with my expectations at the end
of the day when the strikes end it's
still going to take a little while to
sort of get everything going again but
let's wait and see all I can tell you is
that I will keep my ear very close to
the ground I will keep on at the people
that work in and around MGM and Amazon
that I get to talk to and then the
second I find out something you will
know
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you get to see
most of our new videos first and for a
small contribution each month that
really supports a channel you get a free
gift after three months and you get to
watch them without the adverts can't say
fairer than that also go to
sidetrack.co.uk which is our dedicated
website where we do articles for most of
our videos with a little bit more
information in there for you to digest
so please go and check it out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time foreign
[Music]